to every pop song of the 90s and every
like I might dip on salad salad gives me
life life makes me appreciate that I'm
living all right look so give love get
in there
I mean you know put on a sexy movie but
get you goin and follow your favorite
doll film by yourself slip on something
comfortable and get in there just get in
that cell
oh they're so moist in the ball hey guys
I'm Abbi short welcome to a DS kitchen
today we are going to be making a salad
freeways and I know you guys are
probably all thinking such a dietician
move and it is because let's be honest
I'm legally required by my college to
enjoy salad but I'm going to show you
that you can love salad as well and I've
got three amazing versions that are all
my favorites that's going to teach you
how to make friends with salad so let's
do this okay guys so we're going to
start with my spinach berry salad here
and trust me I'm gonna make this [ __ ]
teas good so you're gonna love it
all right so I'm starting with of course
lace finish these are baby spinach
greens and they're super delicious these
ones I've already washed course and
dried them you always want to make sure
you dry your greens really well because
otherwise the dressing does stick it
gets soggy I noted like this veggie
salad we're going to add some beautiful
ripe raspberries for a nice pop of color
blueberries
another favorite weather summer favorite
- such a beautifully colorful salad I've
also got some quinoa here that I cooked
up now one of the things I like to do on
the weekend if I make a big batch of
quinoa and you know chicken breasts and
chickpeas all sorts of different things
little assembly pieces and I can make my
salad with for the week so quinoa is a
really great great grain it's cool grain
got some fiber lots of protein as well
I'm going to mix that right in there and
then I've got some mango as well and
I've got some honest
we toast them up it's got a nice crunch
going on all right we're going to make a
dressing here this is a poppy seed apple
cider vinaigrette
we've got some apple cider going down
I've got a little bit of Dijon mustard
because I like a nice little spicy kick
in there
some honey you can use any kind of
sweetener you'd like it just kind of
also helps bind everything together it's
got some beautiful extra virgin olive
oil and a pinch of salt and pepper and
I've got some poppy seeds because they
are beautiful now people fun factoid for
y'all did you know that poppy seeds are
in our product when are consumed in
excess now are you going to get high
eating the salad you might because it's
so delicious you just feel so euphoric
you might but is it legal yes it is all
right so if I was going to eat this
right away I would dress it right away
because I mean I'm not to eat this with
everything dress but because we're going
to put it aside and have a little party
later a little salad party that you know
you don't want to have soggy salad like
I said before so I'm just going to put
this aside and dress it right before
we're ready to eat and I'm also going to
add my cheese in that at that point as
well
yeah all right next we're going to make
a kale and chickpea tahini salad
so good now we're going to start with
some tahini got some lemon juice here
maple syrup olive oil up and herb got
some lemon zest from a fresh lemon and
some fresh garlic just a little bit you
don't want to speak to garlic in case
you want to make out with someone later
I'm going to add a little bit of pepper
and salt okay so now we're going to get
in there you know a thing about kale is
it's pretty tough it's not like spinach
or romaine or butter lettuce or anything
like that it's it's got a little bit of
a bite and backbone so what I like to do
to loosen it up and what's the best way
to get a little loose a little
loosey-goosey a massage right go to the
massage parlor so we're gonna throw our
kale in here I've also got some cabbage
too a little pop of color and you
actually have to get in there with your
fingers and give it a nice massage in
the dressing not only is that going to
coat it up nicely but unlike the other
kinds of greens like spinach and stuff
that you don't want to dress until the
last minute you actually want to let
this fit out and hang out a little bit
in the dressing to help soften up some
of those tough tough fibers okay so
before I finish the salad I'm just going
to let this soften up in the fridge for
about an hour so so finally my favorite
summer salad of all time my watermelon
cucumber and avocado salad and it starts
with a quick shout so I call them quickl
because they're like quick pickles they
just kind of flavor those shallots
really quickly and they pick that fight
away so I've got some sliced shallots
here nice and fine I've got some lime
juice fresh lime juice to cover a little
bit of water them honey
a little pinch of salt so I'm just going
to let that sit for about an hour so
until it starts to impart that flavor
and
and get nice and tangy and sweet or
salty and yummy so just going to soften
it up take a 5 bombshell
Felicia now we're going to make a lime
dressing a lime chili dressing so it's
tangy it's sweet it's spicy if you are
really good kick it out the seeds in
there so just be careful morning you so
we got some more lime juice into a bowl
a little extra virgin olive oil that's
more honey here got a little Dijon to
get it all incorporated and some spurts
I see red Thai chili obsessed with red
Thai chilies but if you are averse to
heat you can totally leave these out so
get it nice and whiskey with-with-with
we're gonna cut into avocados and sing
about it cuz everything's fun in a song
[Music]
just a nice crosshatch action on both
sides get in there
see it's so nice because they have
already been kind of cut you don't have
to do any other work to them they're
already ready to go now we get to
finally assemble the salad you want to
work fast at this point because the
avocado has been cut you do not want it
to brown so we want to get that dressing
on there as quickly as we can up into
the bowl there we go
cucumber like an English paper because
we've got left keys and water in it
let's get avvocato in there and then you
go in with the dressing and we've got
those shelves we can't forget about
those they've been pickling away all
right so let's get a beautiful platter
to serve this bad boy up all right who
wants to help me with that job got some
feta cheese here little spit a set up
okay a little bit of mint on top to
counterbalance the heat and the chili
all right so now we're going to assemble
our kale tahini chickpea salad so we've
let our kale kind of marinate in that
dressing so it softens up nicely and
it's not like super chewy and
obnoxiously tough I mean they'll be like
the tough kale so let's be real here
I've got some crispy chickpeas I've got
some pomegranate arils
and then I've got some toasted pine nuts
here right on top how good does that
look
I mean give it to me put it in my mouth
all right so now we finish off our
spinach berry salad I'm just going to
start by loading this into a nice Bowl
we've got quinoa in here so I find it's
better in a bold and it is like on a
traditional platter chef's love ghost
cheese this is like a nice soft ghost
cheese I think should just got it all
over my salad here all right we've got
our poppy seed dressing here it's going
to drizzle our greens and
goodness all right guys we got a salad
party going on and I am excited to dig
in
we've got my watermelon cucumber avocado
salad crostini chickpea kale salad and
this awesome summer berry spinach salad
I don't even know which one to go for
for so I'm just going to do a little
eenie meenie miney moe
watermelon it is all right dig in it
it's awesome a song goes so well guys I
hope you enjoyed this video if you love
salads be sure to give this video the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
some of your favorite summer
skyla combinations there are so many
great options the sky's the limit so I
want to hear your go-to of course
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on a beautician
you
[Music]